oscar-winning actress that would be
Jennifer Lawrence is taking a break from
the big screen and turning her focus to
politics
Lauren spoke yesterday at the Concordia
annual summit about her push to pass
statewide anti-corruption laws an
increase voter turnout
some kids are political junkies were you
one of those that you were interested in
politics as a little kid you know I was
I wasn't either I wasn't either now but
now I am yeah yeah no but you said two
years ago after the election yes that's
when it all that's when I started just
trying to educate myself trying to
figure out what I could do we should
strive to build a government that we can
be proud of yeah I don't think that we
should be put off by politics I think
that we should demand better I got
involved because I don't want to be
disgusted by my country's politics what
would be your definition definition of
success as we count the days to Election
Day as we leave the audience today now
high voter turnout yes it's it's very
common during midterms where it's really
just the most polarizing so each side
voting but it's it's more important now
than ever to get out there
Lawrence is working with a group
represent us and she's trying to get
young people engaged politically on a
local level she's sitting there with
Joshua Lynne Graham who is also on the
stage the two of them are working
together listen she said she's been
working for eight years straight just
movie movie movie and after the election
she started doing a lot of reading doing
a lot of research and said I want to
take a year off and just devote myself
to educating myself and educating the
public about what we can do she like a
lot of people are very concerned about
all the discourse and divisiveness in
this country look she's outspoken she's
very smart she's well-read and she
listens a lot yeah I'd love to know what
her reading list is oh she's got one job
yeah all right that would be good we
have a reading group I'll get it for you